let's bring cleaning always had to come
after winter the hell is this oh my god
I thought I had these destroyed after
Wilson gate that will soon fix that
where's my evidence destroying hammer
hey I'm Keri juice you'll be upset
today's the greatest day ever in fact
let's give each other gifts yike hi
doodles badger
evil Nesquik buddy Wow oh my god
maid cafe The Addams Family hello my
name is Maris are you quite all right
yeah fine I was just looking for a black
rabbit you yeah carrying a hard drive
yeah and you escaped from the American
McGee Institute hoping that if you bring
him back it'll prove to the world that
you're not a psychotic maniac that's a
hard note but two or three ain't bad
so have you seen him yet that way Oh
Oh what the hell's going on here
yeah drink this it'll make your
tolerance for overused cliches ten times
smaller
what the hell you talk about I'll forget
it
what's this I'm sorry LSD land you're
not too far off actually
it's Burton
oh Christ
my yeah I'm look at this place like a
coloring book if the only crane
available was gray
oh come now it's not all that bad at
least it's creative
yeah the first million times sure but
the mill even one booth just as bad as
we took over Disney's Alice in
Wonderland well but I love that cartoon
no not that one I hate the fact I had to
make that distinction now no I'm talking
about Disney's Tim Burton's Alice in
wonder
but wait I thought that was a big hit if
it was so bad why did it make so much
money
oh man oh god it's Danny Elfman what's
the matter critic I thought you enjoyed
my musical composition yes for the first
10 years now all your stuff sounds like
the filler music yet skip on soundtracks
oh but critic don't you know that kind
of repetition what makes Burton land so
popular it's TV
but on the spirals everywhere Tim let's
get to fucked up err it's Tim for
everything your style over substance but
it looks good - who cares it's Terry
it's tip but on all angles askew
it's Tim with Auggie lenses tool it's
Tim we're all supporting characters are
kings holding the movies and the wings
and all the Lita that is interesting is
boom it
this world of such uniqueness has been
done a million times a dark and gloomy
out there for suburban X to Y and so
it's saying little hipsters think it's a
more it's still much more whiteness than
original final remix QuickBooks the
making up a ton and anything that's new
is where and yet the style showing wear
and tear but all the profits clearly
there and where the giver we don't care
if I something different we don't dare
cuz I surprised or shocked and I don't
think by the share very good uh we're
looking for the black rabbit with the
whimsical choir if you could just die
with us oh I tried to be nice excuse me
oh my god what are you doing
oh oh oh
dance guy on
Reuben she says we just followed that
road goodie
you go in front of me while I start the
review very good it seems so nice good
night we see a young Ellis being awoken
by nightmares as her father tries to put
her asleep while discussing trading in
business I see strange creatures what
kind of creatures there's a dodo bird a
rabbit in a waistcoat you're mad bonkers
off your hand I think this calls for a
good bleeding
that's what solves every problem in this
time period no secret all the best
people so father so perfect he surely
has to die soon died soon after Alice's
19th birthday this leaves her with a
mother who's certainly a product of the
times who is not willing to accept Alice
because of course she's ahead of her
time and doesn't realize that the ahead
of the times cliche has been done so
many times that actually makes it behind
the times
weasel corset I'm against them but
you're not properly dressed used to say
what is proper what if it was agreed
that proper was wearing a codfish on
your head would you wearing to me corset
is like a codfish oh no it's time for
tired approaching four shades for tired
free-spirited whippersnappers and stupid
yeah most unorthodox I was wondering
what it would be like to fly Oh Oh
uncivilized my father said he sometimes
believed in six impossible things before
breakfast oh heavens to Betsy when in
doubt remain silent
Oh watch better sooner I've always
dreaded ugly grandchildren oh how very
proper didn't if I want to marry him
whoa how obvious ly not stuck-up and
wrong I hope no other character and any
other movie ever made repeat what she
does in this film that would be her
Hamish you have attire
come true I find it invigorating yeah
Behr screenwriting one on one guy's a
good writer focuses on what a character
is not what a character isn't we know
that Alice isn't following the norm
it's an SMS of S or peers and isn't
going to be told what to do well okay
that's all fine and good but what is she
that um blander than bread I can see
you're very close though you won't
mention this to your sister yeah I don't
know I confused are you sure she's not a
product of the emotionless victorian-era
the GABAA supplanted white roses when i
specifically asked the red you could
always paint the roses red and of course
as it goes all the things that elves
will come across inevitably will work
their way into her fantasy world as well
like the owner complaining about the
wife roses talking to tweedle kinda and
tweedle sorta and of course what seems
like an insane society needing to be
challenged will you be my wife but this
happening so quickly so she turns down
the proposal of one of the lesser
Weasley's mostly because she sees the
white rabbit wait a minute so they're
clearly establishing that none of this
is a dream and that it's all reality
okay despite the fact that this is
clearly going against what the original
book was doing why would all these
obvious symbols that worked its way into
the fantasy be presented I know what's
the point if it's all real I mean it's
suddenly being like oh you Santa Christ
oh you doing here I don't know so of
course Alice follows him down the rabbit
hole and things look pretty promising as
the wacky and nonsensical spirit of
Wonderland seems to be shining through
yeah now all she needs is a script that
says write me she of course shrinks down
wearing a convenient mini dress that she
had on her maybe she was gonna play goth
Barbie later and enters the rather gray
and blurry world of Wonderland there is
no life I know found in lie computer
generation I told you she's the right
Alice
I am not convinced oh I'm sorry eeek or
emotional reaction oh I don't know I
guess I'm sticking with nothing she's
the wrong if she was she my man Absalom
all know who she is Alyssa cool with you
things nothing your turn you'll notice
quickly that all the characters speak to
her like they've encountered her before
and that's because they have yeah I bet
you thought you were gonna get the story
of Alice in Wonderland didn't you god I
don't know how the fuck you got that
stupid idea
but no this is a semi sequel not based
on the semi sequel because all the logic
they semi throw in semi makes no sense
unroll the record they inform her that
the Red Queen has taken over with her
evil Jabberwocky and that this ancient
calendar which is never wrong claims
that she will defeat it it tells of each
and every day since the beginning
frabjous being the day you slay the
Jabberwocky that Venu there with a vocal
sword no other swords can kill the
Jabberwocky great another prophecy story
you know why are these so popular why
does everyone go along with something
because the prophecy said so what
reliable source do these prophecies come
from who writes them how do we know they
can be trusted sir Wonderland is
checking up on them
see I told him to check that weird
calendar thing I made up it's a Narnia I
don't know beaver shall lead the way for
the Bedknobs and Broomsticks kids with
the lion king a chosen one matrix chosen
one chosen one Jesus
um let's leave that one up to
interpretation I don't see anyone going
too crazy for that one hey is it me or
does that guy look familiar
nope okay must be one of those but hey
hey hey oh happy day oh happy day what's
he so happy about anybody oh the places
of you if you're looking for strangeness
you needn't look harder
but he's Tweedledum and I'm twiddle kata
oh that's right the ceremonial Johnny
Depp and Helena Bonham Carter
appearances I thought that they were
talented actors playing a variety of
characters they were until they found
their niche playing crazy eccentric
homeless looking people or I'm the mad
header and her the Red Queen we chew up
the scenery scene after scene we act
through bad wardrobe and hair that's
insane and makeup so thick it rival
hunger game we bulge out our eyes and
twiddle our fingers doing this gets us
both around here 10 figures yes and as
you notice neither of them really do
anything different after Alice escapes
one of the Queen's monsters by being
defended by a mouse in the most PG way
possible by the way
meanwhiie shit she comes across the Mad
Hatter who is apparently so mad that he
keeps alternating between accents you're
that salutely Alice I'd know you
anywhere I know him anyway had the
jabberwock with eyes of flame jaws the
baton closed the catch investigating
things that begin with the letter M of
course but now you're back you see and
we need to get on to the frabjous day
you have any idea what that if keen is
done
you've lost your muchness juggling
searching your fault of course is not
very lunacy is only offset by Helena
bonham-carter is not very lunacy as she
plays the Red Queen and actually at
first it almost kind of works because in
the beginning she seems to get upset
over stupid silly things like who ate
her tarts
did you steal no your majesty
that's in keeping with the nonsensical
spirit of the book but for whatever
fucking reason they keep bringing in
this political power struggle and talk
of the prophecy and that's not what
Alice in Wonderland is about it's
supposed to be a fun road trip of
dreamlike nonsense and escape from
reality through creative surrealism it's
supposed to be a childlike experience
not a fucking war movie but listen these
characters constantly talk like they're
in a war movie when the White Queen
once again wears the crown like not
slaying anything done with the bloody
big hair tire world is falling to ruin
by going to rescue him that is not photo
nobody like me oh come on could you see
the man head or getting involved with a
cause a communist flies moonrise can you
see the original Cheshire cat getting
invested with Freedom Fighters
I never get involved in politics oh is
that why you constantly get involved
with political movements every couple of
scenes good why brain sense and logic to
a world that celebrates having no sense
and logic it just sucks the fun out of
it who would want fun when there's glue
instead that's like talking through your
teeth not hearing what's that
we're strike I apologize but they annoy
me you don't whatever on you are you
doing so nice stop killing people
oh I'm afraid I already did and you
looked over there what I didn't look
over there yeah you need a escaped from
a mental institution
I assumed you did too given how you're
dressed yeah but I'm a celebrity when
you dress weird is crazy when I dress
weird it's avant-garde
you
so the hell let's Alice know that
Wonderland used to be ruled by the white
queen played by Anne Hathaway until the
Red Queen Summers heard Jabberwocky to
destroy everything
oh the heartbreaking tragedy if only
there was some sort of warning they
could have had to prepare them for this
like a calendar that predicts the future
and is never ever wrong in a minute then
they say that fucking thing predicts
whatever is gonna happen it tells of
each and every day since the beginning
well why the flying hell were they just
partying that did they miss the part
where we all burn to get our asses fried
you think somebody will put a goddamn
bookmark on that section wouldn't you
that white Queens doing a heck of a job
so the header seats the guards coming
the swings Alice away on his hat which
by the way even then she looks
disinterested oh no I guess and he's
taken away thankfully one of the guards
dogs finds Alice but she discovers that
he's a spy for the rebellion would your
name be Alice miner Jones yes but I'm
not the one that everyone's talking
about the husband would not have given
himself up just for any Alice yes that
would be mad and nothing in his name
indicates he'd be anything like that
what going to rescue him
that is not foretold I've been accused
of being Allison of not being Alice but
this is my dream I'll decide where it
goes from here oh yeah I forgot to
mention Alice this whole time I mean
like 80% of the goddamn movie totally
believes that this is all a dream this
is my dream is my dream
soon a dream I stopped dreaming wake up
from the street time can be funny and
dream sometimes I forget that this is
all a dream I would dream up someone
who's half mad you know I think there's
only so long a person tells themselves
that they're asleep before fucking
reality starts to take effect I mean the
dream excuse can only get you so far
before your other senses start to kick
in for Jim oh it's okay it's just a
dream oh it's okay it's just a dream
it's okay it's just in case you see on
top of that if she does think this is
all a dream what does she care what
happens to the Hatter what does she care
if it's her fault she has no obligations
in a dream
though that again maybe that would
explain why her performance is about as
infested as Willy Wonka saving a bratty
child I'll decide where it goes from
here you diverge from the path I make
the path stop don't come back so she
makes it to the castle where again in a
PG film she climbs over the severed
heads and a bloody river of the Queen's
victims is needed shit and eventually
comes across the captured white rabbit
I've come to rescue the Hatter I don't
know rescuing anyone being the size of a
chapel would he have any more of that
cake that made me gray before actually I
might have some left and this is another
reason why Wonderland doesn't work as a
strategic world of war there's cake that
makes you grow huge whoever has that
shit battle over you win
mass produce that shit and make an army
of King Khan's
you could squash this place like a lego
city faster than you can say curiouser
and curiouser it's like it smells and I
had some of that cake and we suddenly
came across a French I am the terrible
jibber-jabber right of these terrible
movies allow me to make your lives more
needlessly complicated oh dear but no
rather than kill the Queen and her
tracks even though she's a giant she
makes up a story about who she is why
what's the purpose she could bite her
head off like a fucking animal cracker
I've been growing an awful lot lately so
I've come to you hoping you might
understand what it's like anyone with a
head that large is welcome in my court
okay whatever so the Queen takes her in
and Alice eventually tries to break the
header out as well as find the sword to
defeat the Jabberwocky
Tweedles oh okay where's Robert oh this
oh ho that's Wonderland nothing makes
any sense
now they're taking her to where he is
but you just pointed in the opposite
direction are you taking there you not
to give away
is there any goddamn consistency in this
place
should we just rename the characters the
kind of Mad Hatter should we change the
phrase to just a little quirky but still
totally reasonable as a March Hare but
before she can get the sword she has to
deal with this weird scene with the
leader of the guards played by Crispin
Glover like you like Wow Burton's really
working through some issues with this
movie isn't he
next you'll be telling me he has a thing
about rats so she does find the sword
Imagi stew befriend the beast by giving
him his eye back she's unable to save
the header but the bees does carry her
over to Epcot Gondor where the White
Queen awaits come with me
yet only shoot yeah listen we could use
some salt that's my attempt at being
funny it'd be funnier if I was funny
wait a minute they're shrinking her down
well why the flying fuck are they
tricking her down she has to fight that
gigantic Jabberwocky remember do we
forget our little stomp talk come on
guys this makes about as much sense as
the treasure can't wanting to help the
rebellion but uses his godlike powers
just to save one person good morning
everyone
oh come on he could turn into Godzilla
and squash the place if he wanted
there's a bajillion things he could have
done here take a win this war in a blink
of a goddamn eye but hey like he said I
never get involved in politics only when
bad riding dictates so so the Mad Hatter
is saved but they still had to figure
out how Alice is going to defeat the
Jabberwocky on the day of battle which
of course shouldn't matter seeing how
even now she still thinks this is all a
dream
thank God this plot thread has a running
time past five seconds of Tolerance
still believes the dream do you of
course
so come from my own mind okay honey no
offense but you're way too boring to
think up anything is creative as this I
think the most your mind could dream up
is a paper clip on a rice cake that's
how exciting your imagination gets and
yet in a confusing scene even though
they all know it has to be Alice they a
school stand up and fight for the White
Queen who will step forth to be champion
for the White Queen that would be high
know me I'll do it you have very poor
evaporating skills I should be the one
oh that's very big of you seeing how you
never do involved in politics don't
stand has more consistency than you but
then they remind themselves of what they
already know Alice has to do it
Joyce
must be Hugh's because when you step out
to face that creature
why because some magic toilet paper told
you so
why does any of this have to be this way
it doesn't it's total bullshit for a
world that's apparently supposed to have
no rule there sure do seem to be a lot
of rules but wait it gets better
the caterpillar reveals the great big
shocking twist
are you ready oh man this comply you're
my day rate you so shot you're not gonna
play okay you ready here we go here we
go okay you ready here we go
Alice this whole time was Alice wait
what
Alice whoa wait a minute movie so are
you suggesting that the Alice from Alice
in Wonderland this whole time was Alice
from Alice of Wonderland
whoa I mean fucking whoa this movie is
pushing the envelope of cinematic twist
I mean who couldn't see in a common
connect you'll be telling me that Clark
Kent all this time was Clark Kent
ma'am this movie knows how to keep you
on your fucking toes wasn't streamit old
so memory this place is real
so are you in so is that it ding ding
ding what do we have for Johnny
your justice didn't butcher the first
time you were here you called it
Wonderland as I recall it all their wine
you were just as dim-witted the first
time you were here you called it
Wonderland as I recall what's that
called Wonderware what is it call crimes
again standing and under locked
Underland don't let me get this straight
in Alice in Wonderland the story based
on the Lewis Carroll novel Alice is not
a girl she's a woman she's not in
Wonderland she's returning to Wonderland
and wonderland itself in fact isn't
Wonderland at all it's called under lay
under land Angela it sounds like a
made-up world in a fruit of the Loom
Kummer
show I'm sorry how the flying fuck am I
supposed to take an adaptation seriously
when you can't even get one word getting
word of the goddamn title right I'm
gonna say it oh no I'm gonna say I'm
right no don't hold me back oh hell I'll
say it put me this I'm sorry
interpreters in Wonderland is a better
adaptation than apart from at least
giving us what the fucking title
promises care bears in Wonderland and
not under land it still mad nonsense
where everything is backward the villain
of the movie wants to bring sense and
order to it that would be a legitimate
threat to their world so the fear in the
movie is 100% justify here the Queen is
just a jerk but as long as she's as
crazy as the rest of them which she
supposedly is Wonderland oh I'm sorry
under land shouldn't care because unless
you miss what was constantly hammered in
both the story the book every
interpretation ever made they're mad
they're all fucking math so what should
I care about any of this bull crap and
don't get me wrong
Care Bears is an awful movie it's really
bad they do some stupid shit like making
the Queen nice a whole bunch of other
fuck but in terms of which one is closer
to the spirit of what Alice in
Wonderland is I'm sorry the fucking Care
Bears got closer they embrace the
insanity of Wonderland
this one is ashamed to even be called
Wonderland fuck that shit
what um speaking of things we're ashamed
of Hey
oh man I am the Great and Powerful
10-pack Oh goddamn it burn your
nightmare ripping off the right source
material you're destroying The Wizard of
Oz you'll need to do that Sam Raimi
already did that critic why do you hate
my work so much I'm just trying to bring
something creative and new they'll bring
it something creative and new not trying
to destroy what was already fine with
your tire cliches I mean look at his
climax I think the only reason you allow
these annotations to be so wor Hungry's
because you like getting shots of armies
lining up seriously look at all these
movies that you've used them in you're
like obsessed with them hey now come on
those scenes came from Mars Attacks
Planet of the Apes and Batman Returns as
we all know those are critically
acclaimed masterpiece it up it looks so
cool we see Alice dressed up as Joan of
man and they have a dumbass little
battle we meet on the battlefield
that's enough Chetan I'm the wild
eccentric one where I come from
and again in our PG film we get a rather
gruesome decapitation of our fearsome
Jabberwocky
Oh oh hey weeping oh yeah Oh Prima kitty
we follow you no more
so that takes the Red Queen out of power
queen uninteresting is in control again
and the header feels he can finally
celebrate by doing his dance his teeth
oh wait a minute
is Wonderland oh sorry Underland getting
GG I think it is boy he ain't no paper
man he really swings out with the mess
of joy oh my god I've seen anything this
Cronk since I saw vanilla i crack it to
the tune of macaroni jeez ha ha ha Adam
you be dope are you sure you didn't
escape from a mental institution so
Alice goes back home apparently wiser
and somehow even bland ders sorry
English Kumari I love you Margaret this
is my life you're lucky to have my
sister for your wife Lowell there is no
prints on two mijin you need to talk to
someone about these delusions don't
worry mother I'll find something you
and you you wanted a brain what you
don't have is a diploma you and I have
business to discuss
shall we here speak in the stunning my
god her boring personality is in direct
conflict with our boring personalities
so she uses her newfound expertise and
sword fighting and monster slaying into
the training business which this movie
never mentions she has any knowledge of
to begin with it's fast the culture is
rich and we have a foothold in Hong Kong
so she sells the Wonder oh don't you
mean under where she sets to start her
brand-new life
hello absol
really that are big closer I've seen
more fairly conclusions out of bands
named bears
so critic what do you think of my
blockbuster masterpiece I'm sorry I know
a lot of people really enjoy this movie
but I just think it's awful what should
have been a match made in heaven turned
into a needlessly complicated storyline
from a seemingly simple source material
how can a movie based on a pointless
book be even more pointless by trying to
give it a point on top of that the film
thinks that the more evil it can make
the villains the more interest will be
in our heroes rather than just riding
the heroes interestingly you can make it
dark you can make it intense but unless
you have a coherent story and characters
that have a little bit more charm than
snake vomit it doesn't amount to
anything
sometimes the visuals are nice and once
in a while it brings out a little bit of
as a ninis from the book but most of it
misses the spirit the charm and yes even
the wonder that made Alice and
wonderland so great I bet even mallets
could do a more Tim Burton style Alice
in Wonderland sequel than Tim Burton
could come on y'all knew we were going
there but Critic I thought you liked my
work I did when you did original stuff
Beetlejuice Edward Scissorhands The
Nightmare Before Christmas those were
all great but now like you do is
terrible remakes well that's all part of
being an artist critic I mean some ideas
hit bull's eyes and others I bet it all
right but you just keep trying not if
you keep living in another prison shadow
I mean no good could ever come on that I
think this video begs to differ
what now please don't hurt me what is a
creepy girl Ben discernible aged somehow
movies of the critics room when he was
young please don't
well looky here
looks like somebody was living in
somebody else's shadow oh my god you are
a fanboy of me it looks like he has a
full corner of his room dedicated to you
just really liked your work that's all
maybe I did a few fan drawings every
once in a while a lot of that looks
pretty creative most of its crap but
some of its good
you see critic just because you're
interpreting someone else's work doesn't
mean some good can come out of it after
all
did you enjoy Sweeney Todd yeah but and
did you like big fish
yeah but the pen isn't while your
favorite movies of all time my
adaptation of Batman yeah but that
doesn't he's cute bad remake after bad
remake and Alice in Wonderland I'm sure
will never be remade again well just
because it's been done a million times
before doesn't mean I'll be done a
billion times again create this is just
how artists work sure I'll make a lot of
crap but for every Dark Shadows there's
a network for every Planet of the Apes
there's a beetlejuice in fact my next
movie is called big guys based on the
artist who did that kitsch artwork in
the 60s and all the trials and
tribulations she had to go actually that
sounds kind of interesting and based on
another source material
all right for the good of the creative
mind I guess it's good to put up with
some crap every once in a while but wait
there's still one thing I never figured
out why was the black rabbit so happy of
this time no
isn't it obvious this is the first Tim
Burton project to have a black man in a
main role know whether there was Harvey
Dent don't wait now he was in the main
character there was okey-dokey anon
Akili came in the last third oh my god
you're right
see you know for a director who
celebrates black and white you sure to
put a lot more emphasis on the white
they do the black nevertheless go for it
my young one back into the real world to
look forward to the wonders that
burtonll and will bring onto you I will
mr. Burton I know you won't let me down
I'm sure I won't
tim burton's eagerly anticipated me guys
has been cancelled replaced with his
latest cinematic creation Adventure Time
starring Johnny Depp and Helena Bonham
Carter
I completely forgot whatever lesson I
was supposed to learn
you
I like Hajus